let's jump in to our story so this is
the article
the american mind you can hold your you
can hold your ground
against critical theory and there's this
image of
a bunch of very angry people with
pitchforks and baseball bats shovels
one guy's got an axe yeah that's i've i
i i've seen angry mobs depicted in
movies but
this guy's got an axe and he's wearing
some kind of ballistic helmet
that's a pretty serious graphic they got
there but uh i don't i don't think what
you were you guys were going through
involved people with axes chasing you
not literally no
no not literally but uh i guess the gist
of your story is that you run an
organization
and wokeness critical racers started to
emerge and
you guys fought back so why don't you
just tell me from the beginning like
what happened
yeah so i actually joined twitter
almost a year ago because we
were dealing with what we could tell
were some sort of ideological
um strains of thought happening within
the organization
and with those strains of thought some
very specific
um strongly worded requests around
how the organization should proceed so
what does your organization do
right so we're doing the trainings for
people who work with
survivors of trauma so we're training
lay people so people who do not have
clinical training
um in how to better serve the people
that they
are helping cool so then so what
happened with these ideologies
so yeah so it's connected to you know
psychology counseling um
and those fields are
influenced now in part by critical
theory which is an academic theory
and while most people i mean i think the
language is kind of a hard part about
this because you know when you
use the word like woke it's really
loaded and it's becoming kind of a
pejorative and people will resist that
and
you know like okay you're just using
woke to say like anything i don't like
that's coming from the left it's just
sort of this vague word
that catches everything and you don't
even really know what it means
um so let's so so if you don't mind uh
how about i just i'll pull up critical
theory
as wikipedia defines it not the perfect
definition but for those that we want to
avoid you know loaded phrases
they say critical theory is a marxist
approach to social philosophy that
focuses on reflective assessment
and critique of society and culture in
order to reveal and challenge
power structures with origins and
sociology and literary criticism
it argues that social problems are
influenced and created more by societal
structures
and cultural assumptions than by
individual and psychological factors
maintaining that ideology is the
principal obstacle to human liberation
critical theory was established as a
school of thought primarily by the
frankfurt school
theor theoreticians theoreticians
theoreticians
herbert marcuse theodor adorno walter
benjamin
eric fromm and max horkheimer howard
heimer described
a theory as critical in so far as it
seeks to liberate human beings from the
circumstances that enslave them
yeah so this is what marxist liberation
from systems of power and oppression
orchestrated by humans on behalf of
other humans or humans collectivizing in
order to liberate themselves from
hegemonic oppression
so yeah definitely marxian in nature the
thing is though and where it gets hard
is even though people are very
influenced by the ideas of critical
theory and we're seeing this
all over our country at this point you
know in schools in the military in
medicine
um a lot of people who have embraced the
ideas of critical theory
don't wouldn't call it that they don't
know they wouldn't say oh i'm a critical
theorist i believe in critical theory so
while they're while they have accepted
many of the tenets and they're using the
jargon
like oh there are systems of power and
depression and we need to you know
we need to examine these power
structures and make sure that we're not
complicit in
perpetrating abuses or perpetrating
oppression so we're all familiar with
that language at this point
if you were to you know ask the average
person like oh like where would you say
your ideas are coming from they might
say something just like social justice
it's social justice i'm doing social
justice and so it's like that's great
i'm for that you know
but they're not maybe aware of the
actual roots of this thing and how it
the aims of it you know um and so they
end up
aligning themselves with a theory that
is
fundamentally and i mean this is why i
think it's so important to speak out
about it is it's dehumanizing
definitely so and we felt that and so i
mean in terms of that image being
somewhat um
sensational with all the pitchforks and
whatnot it still is and other people
many other people because when i when i
i posted this story on twitter and it
ended up being spread
abroad and so well let's start uh i'll
i'll start from the arg
i'll give you i'll give you a left
argument i suppose okay critical
theory theorists argument so you you run
this organization
and you start noticing you start
noticing this ideology
the first question you'll probably get
is well what's wrong
with someone speaking up and trying to
have you know racial justice within your
company
are you against that no not at all in
fact i share those same values and i
think we might different strategy
and then what happens is when you say i
differ in strategy they say it sounds
like maybe you're
unwilling to investigate your white
privilege or your whiteness or how
you're complicit in this system it
sounds like you're not really ready to
talk
so it quickly shifts from the idea to
you what was the first thing that
happened
that uh that you noticed right so
actually the first
time the rubber really met the road we
were like okay wait a minute so
first of all curtis runs the staff i'm
technically a volunteer for the
organization
and have been on the board the governing
board i couldn't help but notice that
curtis is a white male
you are correct he's also straight
oh he's also cisgendered oh no are you a
christian he's a christian
i'm going to pass out what's that what's
the five things about a trifecta
oh man
jokingly but i do bring it up because
i'm sure that with him running the staff
absolutely that was immediately a point
that people brought up so again i i i
shouldn't uh interrupt but
you know no no did you notice no it's an
important point um well i mean he might
be able to speak to this more because it
was
he was beginning to feel like i don't
even have the right to or
it's hard for me to contradict my own
staff in certain ways
um based on how they're presenting these
things to me as though these are
non-negotiables well so so what were
they presenting like what happened
yeah um i mean
so i would say that the first time that
i
felt like we i ever kind of even hit the
pause button because i
first of all i hired all these people i
love these people they're not
people that are carrying pitchforks
exactly i mean when you try to have
these conversations
of course you're you're being you're
trying to get people's attention so i'm
glad that that we are
attentive to this conversation now and
so all these people i hired them they
did great work in so many ways for so
many years
um we i'm proud of what we accomplished
together and i
love and care about them and it was an
honor to
partner together as well as um
support them in in all the ways that i
was able to
um and the first time that i ever felt
the need to push pause
um on and really kind of analyze their
approach to
um providing the mental health resources
that our organization's mission
offers was when affirmative care came up
and when we were trying to talk through
our guidelines of really being welcoming
inclusive and a space that of course the
shared value
of everybody being able to have access
to
what we had to offer and to feel
comfortable
and and uh be able to uh
receive from that time in that
educational space so it
that is where things began to surface
was around
the strategy of how to uh welcome and
include people
and so right and specifically around
gender identity and the use of gender
pronouns
so it was it was an issue of speech and
compelled speech because at first
was it was this you guys introducing a
policy or is this something brought to
you
like wanting a new policy no so the our
the way
the organization is structured is we're
training organizations we have trainers
who are
contract employees who are all over the
world you know they they're scattered
different places and they lead trainings
for us and then we have a central team
at headquarters that
that oversees the training program so
those training
program staff that began
you know wanting to introduce into the
curriculum this idea of we should be
actually teaching
the people at our trainings about gender
identity and a good way to model that
is to actually more than invite
them at first and they they eventually
realized their their first approach was
not the best
but their first approach was everyone
needs to share a pronoun
whether you know what that you know
whether that's your thing or whatever
like we're gonna we're gonna have
the whole circle share their gender
pronouns i mean there were comical
moments because like we we train
everybody in the world and
even the people who come to where we are
locally and are trained with us
are coming from all over the world so
there are many languages in the
languages that don't have pronouns
uh that's a good or like non-gendered
ones like i think these trainings that
were happening locally were done in
english so anyone who was there was an
english speaker but yes we did we train
in other languages as well and in
contexts where yeah absolutely this
category of gender identity would just
be
completely foreign and inappropriate to
bring up but
um this in the local trainings you know
we'd have moments where you know
a woman from uganda was there at the
training and it gets to her and she's
just like
i don't know what you're talking about
you know like i don't know so it's like
how is this inclusive like you're making
her feel
like she's no idea what's going on this
you know and so they they backpedaled
from that but
it was still their deeply held
conviction
that if you don't bring that category of
gender identity into the space as they
would say it
the people who that category is
important to their identity will feel
erased
essentially um and it's a very
egocentric
yes like world view right right my
my experience trump's yours yes
right um and the
the fact also that even though some of
our training staff were
licensed clinical mental health
professionals these training spaces are
not clinical spaces
so there was that thing too like well
wait a minute like how can we be doing
care like this is a this is a clinical
model of care affirmative care like
we shouldn't even be touching it at all
we're training we're an educational
space
no one is signing confidentiality
waivers to be here no one is receiving
therapeutic care from you
um and so that just kind of that is what
ripped off the
the lid to all of this because i just
was like i don't know what they're
talking about i don't know why this is
such a big deal to them
i don't get it at all i need to start
doing some reading
um and this was probably like three
years ago it's been
it was yeah and that i really started
like i
using some of the jargon that i heard
from them on a regular basis i just
started
reading so intersectionality and it was
a big word that i heard them use and um
that was kind of where i started and
then that that launched me into this
world of critical theory this is why i
say woke and i don't say critical theory
critical theory is one aspect of what
exactly
what we're seeing but then you have
intersectionality then you have fourth
wave feminism and all these different
ideas
and so i understand that you know woke
might be loaded because you've got a
culture war going on
but it's more of an umbrella term for a
variety of authoritarian
ideology right it's it's very it's it's
uh uh
it's it's a moral framework that
believes in their own superiority much
like many fundamentalist religions it's
unassailable you can't examine it you
can't challenge it
right so so that to me was what raised
the red flags was like
hey i'm i'm totally happy for you to
disagree with me like that's why we
hired
diverse people you know we wanted the
strength that comes from different
perspectives
but when you tell me i must accept your
conception of reality and i can't even
ask questions
because asking questions alone reveals
that i'm i'm revealing like my
resistance to even being a good person
or something by asking questions like oh
i don't want to investigate my
cis heteronormative you know whatever um
i was like you know
that to me is like cultish language you
know where it's like this
this doctrine must be accepted and to
ask is proof
first of all first of all that the
injustice is happening that you're
questioning you know what is ibrahim x
kennedy's
always saying the heartbeat of racism is
denial so so it's this
proving that he himself is one of the
most abhorrent racists in on the planet
i mean literally by his own world view
the man itself is one of the most
unrepentant
and that's a really important point is
you have to hold them to the standards
that they're holding to you
and then when you hold them to those
standards that's when you start to
realize like wait a minute this isn't
actually about
a good faith dialogue because i just
applied your standard to you but now
you're
it's there's it's asymmetrical exactly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you